okay [ __ ] okay pitches and are
snitches and at all you other people oh
we're here up here in Jackson connick a
mutha [ __ ] we have a bladed Wilson I
don't remember the control so there's a
good chance at when someone shows up I'm
not gonna know how to [ __ ] an attack I
can we just check ticket shows i just
checked the controls okay okay I how do
you do the spider set [ __ ] I got it okay
okay I get get get all right let's do
this match has let's do this come on are
you all right [ __ ] for go down there let
me check see nothing in here okay oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] crow so much for this road
River delete a straight to tell me sorry
tom is straight to Thomas
you know um I never liked Tommy I'm just
gonna say that right now tommy was never
really the best what I mean but he's had
a bit of a discipline Tommy's all the
world one way I saw the other and that's
why he joined the fireflies yeah your
friend Marlene promised him hope I kept
him busy for a while but just like Tommy
he eventually quit that too last time
you saw I believe his last words to me
where I don't ever want to see your
goddamn face of me exposing here sign up
without his help okay I also think it
doesn't help that um I slipped one time
and fell on his deck I just figured you
know we're all being honest here I might
as well just talk about it and I like I
might as well just talk about it okay
baby
gass Wow JS sucking music again I feel
[ __ ] wet already I can he go Stover
here if I can take us looking for ghosts
he says
right there's a hydroelectric power
plant
it uses the rivers movement and turns it
into electricity look I know what it is
I don't know how it does it what is this
can take this now how are we getting
across ah it's easy just about physics
[ __ ] it's just simple physics
okay we got to get across here and this
is halfway forget the other one up we'll
make it across okay that's what my wife
said to me before she sent me to divorce
paperwork okay Hey oh it Glitch like
right about here just free this [ __ ]
chat hey this [ __ ] [ __ ] nuts no I'm
so glad oh god oh god I need you to
[ __ ] palette get on the palate Ali
another trial not a [ __ ] palate come
on yeah my god it can head cat
it's like real [ __ ] do I launcher over
here hell yeah
yeah good get up there [ __ ] okay the
meantime let me just check the hip I can
get into that building right now because
last time was blocked it was blocked
like a [ __ ] along fine yeah give it a
spin Bette Davis fan
I'll shoot down that let me check here
Oh locked up jokes on him from Philly
okay there we go kk god ok gud get gud
get gud gud gud gud gud yeah thanks
[ __ ] ok let's get let's go
oh shut the [ __ ] up Pech what yes don't
strike children kids okay what's down
there I go this way let's check out this
place first I never saw bamboos I'm way
as well check this place out mmm he will
flip out usually when I know what the
[ __ ] his ass that's too small great got
to leave that stupid robot on his grave
what should I do with it early what I
want to talk about it no why how many
times we go over this please heaven
that's enough
sorry dad told me Lee they're right here
hey open up over here let's go over here
and climb a [ __ ] badger all right hot
on abrir i know i am to just get past
this place then we can scrounge up some
food I miss a lot Shep a [ __ ] it I don't
like backtracking nice [ __ ] i like ya
ain't no way around gonna cut through
the plant cut their the plant now you
really sound like my ex-wife okay hey I
get on their head in there now huh very
second that was a construction worker
you know that I could just go in know
how to get that I think that's also quit
what the [ __ ] is that at a que el Diablo
yeah chase okay what's over there yeah
she's something there right what's hide
can you go around no I can't that be
crazy I'll be crazy okay how again this
[ __ ] Oh triangle of course
don't even think about reaching for your
weapon tell the girl to drop hers now
Hayley it was the lady said Cara hey
what happened of these I I we're lost we
didn't know the place was occupied we're
just trying to make our way through
through to where they're all right but
you know these people know him that's
how my goddamn brother Tommy holy [ __ ]
oh they gonna kiss out though they're
gonna kiss are you doing my brother god
damn yeah let me look at you they're
gonna catch sold out never easy don't
happen to you hello lady this is Maria
be nice to her she sorta runs things
around here hi I'm Arya your face a
Illinois Lee thanks for not blowing my
head off would have been embarrassing
considering you're my brother-in-law oh
shat I guess she is offline that we all
gotta get wrangled up at sun che le
right yeah what brings you through here
uh
that's kind of a long story why don't we
bring him inside that's how me hand it
out you hungry starving
what I think Tommy just kels a guy false
alarm they're friendlies we've been
dealing with raids it's been quiet for a
few days what the hell are you doing
here I thought I'd find you in Jackson
you trying to bring the plant back to
life okay is that way uptown I like to
meet her thanks to me Kara alright no
we'll get along again no way you guys
have horses we got a whole lot of them
hey Tommy came with it do you think I'll
be right back he's using off ba can you
allen wrench from the horses tits as
[ __ ] up you ever ride one I actually
have are you hiding the horse Winston
this soldier back in the zone he gave me
lessons oh no press triangle for his
awesome awesome ooh triangle through our
basileus we're here hey thanks Donny how
they fix this one up okay all right
let's continue the tour I got got got
got got okay okay let's continue the
tour [ __ ] let's continue the tour
that's all time why are you here were
you supposed to head back this morn well
you'll waiting on Hauser and the rest of
the boys to relieve me are my labia
batch I'll never leave you right now so
you got the money it's just getting it
illegal ahead or am i okay okay come on
betcha you walk a little slow for me I'm
not old you know you may be kind of old
I'm not okay okay okay right now here we
go Priya yeah go ahead on the control
room stinks about to start it back up
you want to come check it out I'd rather
eat with Ellie it's my turn anyway I'll
go I'll come with you go with Marie's
include but that food and yeah girl come
on Ellie let's get the poison did you
hear what I said he's like Oh nuts he's
gone nuts he's like a tank regiment
Tommy over
this would be the sixth time of them
trying to get the turbines back online
hmm we've been here just a week it feels
like forever okay well uh let's get the
helm at an engineer so I'm just gonna
say it's good I got something for you at
work brothers we can't let you know
we're back to Texas huh what's our stuff
is long gone most eyes a [ __ ] up there
and even now I is it here it's a little
faded it still looks pretty good uh-huh
I'm good I'm good you sure I mean I said
I'm good ever faced a lot of oil idiotic
okay clean your face one throughout the
south don't do it for you tell me yet I
need to talk to you privately yeah okay
okay let me just check out my guys will
get pray awkward come on back great how
would you bet on attacks and a half and
I'm not gonna be able to [ __ ] lock
them i say we're running how that's good
yeah the game let's break out that way
so i'm gonna go this way oh yeah you
know my favorite thing is when going the
new society to just take all their [ __ ]
let's take it all hmm i really i love
this pitch out to watch at a time it's
always actually goes an actual sniper
what's a [ __ ] ok I got gone this way
I'll this way
I don't know what you heard but you
should see the town we're over twenty
family strong now it was Maria and her
father and they set up this place from
the idea of being self sustained we have
crops and livestock remember how we
thought no one could live like this
anymore we're doing wow where's Anna oh
look at this vegetation I like a push
him lost take charge guard the perimeter
he'd got electrified fence when planted
have you still got a deal with infected
though right who doesn't notice the
world we live in hmm yeah I don't holy
feel that brother I totally throw that
you sound like Marlene uh yes I am
Marlene ok ok I shed what is that no
[ __ ] way idea when it is ready that's
buckling not much of a gardener is a
good boy yeah he's kid hi by clay what
what is this I'll take that stank you
are we taking us thank you I'd make
anything yeah I can make a lot Oh
Michael Nutter you just get [ __ ] go sour
but any a bunch of these bet your dread
here ok so in those [ __ ] buddies I
guess you know no and why not you know
what it is ok ok get ok these two
geniuses are gonna bring this plant back
to life thanks brah we think we got it
this time
you don't believe us I believe it when I
see it engineers I went to an art school
make it two and the first thing they
teach us there is that science isn't
real let's do this that's dead ass
mm-hmm okay good luck watch it
yes okay that's good lower it slowly I
[ __ ] on the wrong side I mad [ __ ]
through all the perks at them alright
that's good Tommy share we good to go hi
Cal ready go ahead get it we did it boys
the jack pilots mark voice isn't area
Lord again for me the good news I'm arm
around you see that pretty impressed yes
I see that it's like your appt 2 million
bucks all right Joe what is that let's
go talk why don't have to keep moving to
talk look really attacked we got a
[ __ ] talk to you ok obviously if
there's gotta be something around here
probably
brick make secret [ __ ] i can pick up
here here we go this is the [ __ ] i was
looking for but not my thing has hey
ok
ok do I need it
squat the crew you got here can't act
like a good man this place gives him the
second chance give this all second
chance so why'd you leave Boston I've
been on quite the adventure little
brother I reckon he's got something to
do with that girl has got everything to
do that little girl hmm ok well go on in
she's immune immune to what in how I
I'll see come on I know after to breathe
enough spores that take down a dozen men
nothing I wouldn't believe didn't either
but I can show you all right I'll bite
why bring her here I supposed to deliver
to the fireflies the way I figure
they're your boys you finish the job you
collect the whole damn payment I'm seen
a firefly years you know where they are
now I'm not asking for much time I just
want some simple gear enough to set me
on my way what makes you think I'd do
this for you this isn't for me Tommy
this is for your damn cause my cause is
my family now you ain't talking about
some walk in the park here Jesus boy
have Maria get some of your bored again
friend to do it they got families to
tell me I need this chat you want some
gear sure but I taking that girl off
your hands this is how you gonna repay
me huh repay you for those goddamn yours
I took care of us took care that's what
you call it I got nothing but nightmares
from those years you survived because of
me it wasn't worth it I bring you the
Cure from mankind you wanna play the
pissy little brother way back in Boston
you lay your hands on me again it won't
end well for you
oh yeah like I guess we're under attack
they're gonna cast you'll remember how
to kill right yeah [ __ ] bandit stop him
don't let him into the building holy
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] I gotta hit hard gay wears
all right
is the next I got them all right cracker
come on I'm sick too [ __ ] far away
all right in the [ __ ] guys
that's how I play it [ __ ] that's
outside oh [ __ ] but you're still alive I
hear more things going on
I carry left Camelot Oh excess swap ok
no we're trapped we're gonna come to you
just they're here le hi Maria yeah all
right what why'd it where the [ __ ]
everyone go ok that's my guy
ok
what the [ __ ] oh oh oh oh Sarah and
moving pretty [ __ ] bad with this gun
can't wear you [ __ ] na
ouch
she [ __ ] like college guys
ok wherever you got to go
I see 1 i'll throw out please don't
their eyes okay good hello dispatch
I'm a hunter
Bridge Hill it seems almost on the
[ __ ]
we got to get to the girls right behind
you wow this way Joe oh [ __ ] that I run
fast okay Chet Kent's game koenig leche
okay uh probably heal up right here I'm
guessing
oh that's the girls I'm in the [ __ ]
face so who survived he's so mad ok and
I need to quickly check the area you
okay yeah yeah yeah I'm fine oh yeah
we're coming in from every direction the
Maria was like we gotta run and so we
don't over these tables and this huge
guy blasted so desolate listen hey hey
are you hurt no god damn it I need to
talk to you absolutely not you tell him
to go find somebody else do you have any
idea how many men we lost her today
what's that all about trying to sell ya
cat said of anything to do with me talk
about it later did he tell you where the
lab is i'll talk about it later later
right
one [ __ ] up and then I turn into one of
those widows ok I have to do this I
don't know what else to say kiss her
kiss her fine Maria here we go you if
anything anything at all happens to him
it's on you she's thankful you know I
know I'll take that girl yours to the
fireflies you don't have to worry about
it's best this way now maybe some real
good will come of this I need to talk to
Ellie nice shot say again I didn't hear
you Joe wait what is it that girl of
yours she took one of our horses and
rode off which way come on just saw her
riding on out of here go back inside
help the others clean the place up ok ok
let's go get this batch there yeah
that [ __ ] this you live now I gotta keep
on hitting okay she couldn't gone flower
move on don't worry checks yeah yeah
yeah yeah bullies not nothing like this
uh yeah yeah yeah yeahs little are say
yeah uh yeah yeah yeah yeah let's go a
little horsey yah she didn't go down
this way the horse ate her
hey what's obviously I'm a girl that
[ __ ] that's how I antia i knows she
can't sir I like what is she trying to
pull here for trucks that way but yo I
like the keeper of the horses okay a
little fast our [ __ ] [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
this horse a slosh up sure
however how many you see took goddamn
mini go around I'll cover you okay
where's the other one on his head step
on his head good good come on [ __ ] I'm
heading this way you will check over
there I know you're here
ah oh [ __ ] I guess I'm [ __ ] shoot me
in the [ __ ] face you're gonna hard
ahaha [ __ ] oh what the [ __ ] Oh Sarah
okay okay we're in business I get that
guy though he just has to be in the air
oh that's my guy out out out out owl
where's that [ __ ] I'm triangle in this
match is gonna die oh yeah yeah what's
right come on step out again I got cut
I'll [ __ ] after all this
any health in here I [ __ ] use this
yes that's all of them okay and yeah I'm
with this house real quick okay nothing
in here nothing here oh there's some
goodies right here Alleluia I look grace
ok hey buddies ok bad guys ok you know
my I got to [ __ ] out this guy and I
have any [ __ ] this guy good yes I'll
take that bet you said she's my bone
heromore ok what about over here with
hillbilly tom s the [ __ ] like I dargah
to get back on my horse hey oh do the
horse [ __ ] die too because it jumped
over nothing's there Oh [ __ ] ankles
are rightly know he's okay my voice all
I've come on back to the horses oh oh
hello Jessica as if it's gonna get honor
okay uh yeah Betsy yeah
how uh yeah yeah uh yeah good guys you
got tip drag skate going this way uh
sure I hope these tracks up late to my
ex-wife you know cuz happy awkward
happen soon hair like here months
le how do you can sneak the home people
now we'll just like pop through there's
none o yo get out of Jenna
Oh anyone is to again this guy decided
to sell la fat guy but I guess you ever
heard of Mike let our course so
naturally we looking for sure look by
the ranch that's all horse she's gotta
be there oh yeah okay okay i'll buy it
maybe maybe she sure that's like
personal hygiene chat you know i can't a
girl i can get it you know you don't
want to be like yeah aunt am I sticks
out for her Amish